i'm feeling wonderful i think you know
it's what i really needed you know i
wanted to win that game last night but i
think that my mental health is better
being out that outside of that house you
know because you know i had enough of
todrick and his lies and his you know
deception and you know he played a very
mean cutthroat game and i don't think it
was a good game to play
um
you know i played more of a a fair game
i think you know i played more of the
big brother good game you know just
trying to lay low play the game try to
win something see how far you can get
you know i um
i think mentally for me i'm a lot
happier being out of that house that's
for sure
i don't need to win at a point that it's
going to cost me my mental health
no absolutely um you know it's you're
saying this um about todrick was this
something you would realize during the
house because in your exit interview
with julie you talked about how his game
played
yeah you know i thought it was a good
game play i thought it was a good way
the way he played it because i thought
you know but then when i saw
all the other stuff and i saw him the
way he talked bad about us you know
about me you know and him she's agreeing
with everything i realized that no
that's not the way to play the game i
thought he played a good game but no he
played a terrible game and i think that
he's going to pay for it once it gets
out of the house with the people
well you know and um a big thing in big
brother especially in the last few years
has been jury management oh yeah
how would you say chadrick has done on
that i don't think he'll get a vote i
personally don't think that anybody's
going to vote for him you know i think
that his jury management is terrible and
that's something i was concerned with
with me i was like i gotta keep the good
jury management so i think you know once
i got out and saw everything i had a
good jury management i can get enough
votes to win the game um and i think
that they knew that they both knew that
and they both knew that's why they had
to get me out of the house you know and
um
you know it's just so funny to re-watch
stuff over that you didn't get a chance
to see
and wow man it's it's it's really
amazing to see stuff cause you stuff
that you i thought i like i think the
last four days five days i think i knew
what toddrick was like i knew who he was
and i knew that he was you know the guy
tried to i think and when i really
stealed his fate with me was when he
tried to tell me how television worked
and i'm like how can you tell me how you
ain't never you haven't been on the
series in your life don't y'all tell me
how sometimes tell me how the nelson
ratings worked you know and you know and
i was like come on man really and i just
looked there i didn't want to say
anything and see misha will protect him
you say something about him me she's
going to come back and attack at you you
know so i was like okay i want to keep
it you know chill in this house you know
so i'm not going to say anything you
know and that's what i realized you know
so
um
you know do you think even if let's say
cynthia's sitting next to him that he
might have like
if cynthia is sitting next to him
cynthia will win
okay we get all of our votes got you we
just don't you know i just don't want
you know i don't want neither no i wish
i could work for some vote for somebody
else i don't want neither of them to win
now the stuff i saw them say yeah
and i'm sure everyone else that that i
better have a house i've seen the same
thing but saw it much earlier when they
got up they didn't see when they're in
the house i'm sure carson didn't see it
but he saw it out of the house
um yeah i um you know i feel like
um watching again normally with big
brother the jury doesn't get to watch
the live video you don't get to watch
that and so i don't know if that was
maybe something he wasn't taking into
account do you know if that was ever
something discussed in the house you
know i don't i think that he
knew but he couldn't help himself
i don't think you know i think that's
who todrick is so he can't help himself
you know he likes to get in and weave
those little ways and like he's like the
one that everything he's experienced
everything you know for 35 years old he
experienced way more than he than he
believed in his head he's experienced
way more than but in fact the matter is
he hasn't you know and if you watch him
like you know he's just amazing he has
all this money he's doing this and that
and he got all these cars and he throws
all these parties he's paying for
everyone flying driving bustles in and
misha just ate it up like like she does
her food just ate it up so well and just
you know i think that she's going to be
really surprised when she gets out and
finds out the truth about him it's going
to hurt her feelings i know it's going
to hurt her and then she's going to
realize who her real friends really were
um you know i did see that you posted um
you know an apology to shayna have you
had the chance to talk to shayna yet not
not yet but i'm sure i will if i don't
talk to you on the phone before we get
there wednesday i will definitely
apologize a person you know i got caught
up in that too you know they caught me
up you know and i you know it's not fair
to talk about someone how somebody
dresses just not right and and um
and when i
what made me realize i knew i i knew
what i had said i knew i had to
apologize but even more when i saw
todrick saying those things about me and
and it is hurtful and it's not right you
know and i'm just happy that i can be a
person who can apologize you know when i
know i'm wrong you know and i just hope
she accepts my apology but i'm sure
shayna's is
is old enough and smart enough like i am
to accept people's apology and move
forward uh me and shayna and all the
rest of cars and all of us would be
great friends you know um i don't see a
world where todrick is in there i just
don't see that i think that we now know
how he really feels and who he is you
know by the way he played the game
um you know uh something i did want to
talk to you about is your great
relationship with lamar i mean i
you know
i
i think it was so lovely the way he
spoke about you both with julia and in
my interview that i just did with him
was so lovely what is it about the two
of you that you think you connect with
so well i think i connect with lamar
very well because i can relate to him
what he's going through and his
struggles and i think that i've been
there and i'm past that and i know that
i can help him with a lot of stuff to
get even further past where he asked um
i think that as um
as uh the age that i'm at mar i think
mars like 41 i believe and i'm 56 i
think that you know recovery is a big
part of my life you know um
but we have to learn how to use it and
how to wield it and i think that lamar
has to just know that you know he's got
to start listening to someone what i
always say is if you don't listen to
somebody like your sponsor you don't
listen to what they're telling you
because they've gone through that then
you're going to mind someone eventually
and you don't want to be you know the
law or something else you know because
you know drugs are an evil thing that's
destroying our country you know we
haven't gotten a hold of it yet um on
top of drugs is mental health you know
we need to keep our mental health right
i think lamar i can help lamar with a
lot of that stuff to to weave his way
around this stuff you know tactfully and
smartly and to keep himself out of
harm's way you know like there's no
reason for you know somebody and who we
are to be going to a nightclub partying
there's no reason to be there you can do
a lot more fun things than be there and
put yourself in a dangerous situation
you know um
and i think he just needs to hear it
more and i have to keep putting it to
him keep putting them and then he
doesn't understand i gotta keep hitting
him over the head wait until he gets it
until he realizes that you know he's
better than that and we both have been
that we don't need those things in our
life anymore there's so many other
things in life that are beautiful than
that
that's wonderful that's it's so nice to
hear you talk about that um
so obviously i feel like in big brother
you know it was sometimes it seemed like
you were like oh you know if i go home
and go home and then other times you
were like you're planning to win it i
mean
that was my strategy
that was definitely my strategy was to
make them think that i didn't care about
it and it worked for until four it
worked for a long time people thought
that i didn't care about what i was
doing and then all of a sudden my bam
when somebody's like hey hello i'm here
now you know and then i was then i had
to be wide awake and on my toes at all
times because that's because topic was
good you know he had me believing some
stuff and then i had to really catch up
on wait a minute is he telling me truth
but there's no place you can go and be
alone and really think about it because
somebody's always there and then then
you know if you got alone i'm talking to
lamar tommy comes in he's like you know
and then he'll start on his thing and he
he talks for like five million times you
know and you can't hear listen to
anything else you can't when he starts
talking he can't listen to your own
thoughts in your head
i mean the guy is very good at weaving
mischief he's very good at weaving
mister you know it kind of reminds me of
um you know when you're uh talking to
people you know when you've got the
angel and the devil on your side charger
comes in he's very good that double gun
and they said this and i came and i was
you know i was trying to save you really
you cut my throat you were never trying
to save me you were trying to put
yourself in position that's why you got
me because i was first in line with
misha got me farthest away from misha
you know but i think that what's going
to happen is like i said when misha gets
out she gets a chance to see everything
people start telling her what was really
going on she's going to realize that she
did have some real friends in there and
she had somebody who doesn't care much
about her you know and and i and i'm
hoping that she sees that so she can
learn uh who taught you i think todrick
needs i don't think he needs a lesson
but he needs to know that it's not right
the way he played that game you know and
i think that if people tell him that you
know i will accept this apology if you
ever apologize of course i will doesn't
mean i'm going to be friends with him
but i'll accept his apology
okay would you be friends with misha
yeah i would be but i think she owes me
apology for the thing she said to me
last night when i was gone it's terrible
you know i never said anything like that
about her you know and i think that she
needs to you know i think but she
toddrick she's she's been eating
todrick's juice for a few days like two
weeks now she's been sucking up all that
stuff eating all that food you know
topic information he's giving you that's
just not correct you know just like the
things that he to find out tonight when
i got home was to find out that all
things she said about shayna was just a
big
made-up crap you know it may have been a
one percent something there but the rest
was all todrick making it all up you
know and but look me carson we all ate
it we all ate it up you know chewed it
up and swallowed it and then reacted the
same way and the rest of us who voted to
put her out we all did that you know uh
well i have only a short time uh left
but i just want to ask what surprised
you the most about big brother
what surprised the most about brother is
how um secluded you are how lack of
information you get you know and how it
can really play tricks on your mind you
know i mean i mean when i was in there i
mean last night even when i woke up last
night i was doing some stuff i got to
the point where i was like wow this is
tough and i you know you start
seeing like like i was having dreams
that i you know like i had my cell phone
and then my cell phone didn't work and
they were somebody was chasing me with
myself and i was like no i got to make
it work you know then when you start
having dreams like that it is time to go
you know what i mean time to get your
suitcase and get out of there